this video was sponsored by the purge on
USA Network a 10-episode television
event premiering on Tuesday September
4th will you hide or will you seek tune
into USA Network every Tuesday to make
your choice and seal your fate
you don't need us to tell you that
there's too much to watch these days
even months before Halloween 2018 had
already delivered a number of standout
horror movies many of them flying under
the radar so we've collected our
favorites for one reason or another all
of them were overlooked but they're all
worth a second chance
Terra Fire sometimes a horror fan wants
something intellectual and sometimes you
just want to watch people run from an
insane clown trashy exploitative and
mean-spirited Terra Fire is the sort of
movie that's meant to be discovered on a
beat-up VHS tape except instead of being
pumped out into dollar theaters in the
80s it was somehow released in 2018
Terra Fire commits to its trashiness
from every angle
it's simplistic low budget and sometimes
dubiously acted which is not to say that
it's a bad movie while it's certainly
not for everybody the movie has notched
a solid 80 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
meaning slasher fans should feel
confident giving this punchy thrill ride
a late-night spin high walk it what if
you made a nasty wish in a fit of rage
only to find out later that you couldn't
take it back
hi wocket tells the story of a teenage
girl who naively puts a curse on her
mother in a half-baked woodsy ritual
after her moment of frustration has
passed the girl has to watch as her
curse becomes terrifyingly real and the
consequences close in around her Pie
wocket is a movie from the slow burn
school of horror favoring mood over
scary moments and a sense of dread over
jump scares elevated by strong
performances from its mother and
daughter leads the movie sports a
concept relatable to anyone who's ever
been a teenager especially a teenager
who's made a big mistake or two wildly
wildly isn't just an underappreciated
horror movie this unsung character study
is one of the best movies of the year
the story of a young woman raised in
captivity who enters the real world as a
teenager it's a feral child story that
takes its premise very literally a
supernatural horror movie wild Lane
brings out its fantastical elements
slowly drawing you into its world of
believable characters well before it
reveals what it really is it's a movie
that tests your allegiances as a viewer
with your sympathies constantly shifting
as the circumstances change it's also a
movie of adolescent self-discovery with
a particularly wild twist starting like
a supernatural version of the movie
wild lane basically turns into predator
by its third act and appropriate
transformation given the subject matter
revenge
left for dead in an isolated location a
young woman is forced to hang on to her
life as the criminals who nearly did her
in come back to finish her off for good
over the course of revenge
she turns from a carefree hedonist into
a vengeful destroyer the circumstances
of her near-death experience are so
brutal and unfair you've never wanted to
see the bad guys get what's coming to
them as badly as you do hear a vicious
adrenaline pumping look at savagery and
survival revenge is not a comfortable
watch basically being a cross between
127 hours and I Spit on Your Grave but
if you've got the guts to watch it it's
a trip well worth your time the
strangers prey at night a surprise hit
when it invaded theaters in 2008 it took
the producers of The Strangers a decade
for a follow-up to be realized
enthusiasm for the first movie faded in
the time between releases and the sequel
landed in theaters with a much more
muted splash but fans of the original
strangers shouldn't ignore this second
go-around which may be better than the
original moving the action from a
couple's home to an empty trailer park
prey at night effectively builds on the
originals premise of pointless random
violence it can't be reasoned with
it can only be fled the sequel gains
points over the original for the target
families tendency to fight back making
the game of cat-and-mouse much more of a
level playing field than it was in the
original and ultimately making this a
more rewarding watch mom and dad written
and directed by Brian Taylor one half of
the directing duo that brought the world
the crank movies mom and dad is a look
at the most out of hand family squabble
you've ever seen it's as though they
took a mundane argument between parents
and their children
added Nicolas Cage and well made a crank
movie out of it simple and brutal mom
and dad is a cathartic and chaotic
horror comedy with all the best Nicolas
Cage weirdness you could ask for up to
and including an enraged performance of
the hokey-pokey that involves a
sledgehammer it's not every film goers
favorite flavor but if you're still with
this video you're probably the target
audience